le da el visto bueno a la adhesión de
Suecia la otan un giro en la posición
del mandatario Turco que había mantenido
durante meses poniendo en la cuerda
floja el deseo del país europeo
me complace anunciar que como resultado
el presidente arduan acordado remitir el
protocolo de adhesión de Suecia a la
gran asamblea nacional lo antes posible
el compromiso se dio en un encuentro
entre erdoan y el Primer Ministro ulf
kristerson una que tuvo lugar
previamente al inicio de la Cumbre anual
de la otan en lituania ahora debe ser
refrendada en el parlamento Turco
estamos dando un gran paso hacia la
rectificación formal de la membresía de
Suecia a la otan ha sido un día bueno
para Suecia
con la Guerra de Ucrania como telón de
fondo el año pasado Suecia y Finlandia
pidieron conjuntamente hacer parte de la
alianza cambiando su posición de no
alineación militar que mantenían desde
hace décadas con el objetivo de
blindarse de Rusia Finlandia logró su
cometido pero Suecia había sido
bloqueado por Turquía ya que todos los
miembros de la alianza deben aceptar la
entrada de un nuevo integrante erdogan
argumentaba que Suecia albergaba
integrantes del partido de los
trabajadores de kurdistán un grupo que
considera terrorista ahora los líderes
de ambos países se han comprometido a
retomar las negociaciones de una
eventual entrada de Turquía a la Unión
Europea Hungría también tiene que
aprobar la membresía en el pasado su
Primer Ministro Víctor urbano se había
comprometido a dar el sí luego de que lo
hicieran cara